Oh, hello!
Hi, I'm a friendly box
I'm a friendly box!
Who loves to...
YOU BEST S-... OH MY GOD
OH, JEEZ! I'm being SHANKED
JESUS
OH GOD!
Jacksepticeye: This is so much better than OVERWATCH!
HELL YEAH!!
Where's my ultimate BOXABILITY?
PewDiePie: I'm gonna make a montage of this game
Jack: AWW NOOO
AYY! ANOTHER FUCKING BOX!
Jack: ANOTHER FUCKIN' BOX
Hang on , I don't have enough bullets
PewDiePie: AWWW, NO don't...
PewDiePie: Ah! guys , Check the bottom of the map. IT'S REALLY COOL.
Mark: Ohhh. I see that
Is that fireworks down there?? (yes)
NICE!
Huh he hah ho hue AAHAHAOW
AHAHA-ow
PewDiePie: YOU F*CKING BOX
PewDiePie: COME BACK HERE YOU F*CKING BOX!
Mark: You can't hit what you can't see!
Son of a...
Ahhh F*CK
He's too good at it!
HE'S BEEN PRACTICING FOR DAYS
PewDiePie: MY MOM WAS A BOX
PewDiePie: I see you guys , goin- NO! NOOOOOOOOOOOOO
(Mark laughs) (PewDiePie screams)
Jacksepctieye: I thought you didn't see me!
Yeah! Take that Guest5910!
Pewdiepie: Don't steal my f*cking kill
My kill :P
Come at me box bro!
Jacksepticeye: I don't have enough health for this.
(mark's mating call)
Awwww FUCK
CinnamonToastKen: Eat my box
PewDiePie: Ken right away wants to create a fanfiction of boxes
Jesus, I just spawned...
(Laughing)
CinnamonToastKen: Im o- I'm on top, very top
Oh yeah, are ya?
Jacksepticeye: Aww man, there's (range?) CinnamonToastKen: That's what's shootin'! PewDiePie: No!
(Grunts) GET SHANKED!
Get shanked..
(Jack) WHOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
(Mark) EUUUGGGHHHH (Mating call?)
Booz
HA HA HAHA (Evil mark laugh)
I'm a man on a mission- AAAH
Jack: NO, NO! Ken: You gotta- you gotta box cutter
(Laughing) YEAAAHHH!
Awww. That was- that was my kill!
OH, YOU BITCH!
I'M COMING FOR YOU!
UEGH EGH AGH UEGH
AAAH
PewDiePie: Stop calling it camping
PewDiePie: Others call it....
AGGHHH - (Whimpers)  Pewds: Boxing
Jack: OWHAOW Mark: I HATE THIS GAME!
Jack: THIS GAME IS DUMB AND YOU'RE ALL STUPID!
This game is stupid...
Jack: Felix is winning and I don't like it- OW!
Poods: GOT PROBLEM WITH ME WINNING?!
Ken: Pew, pew pew! Jack: OW OW OW OW OW!
Are you healing or something?
Jack: AH! Mark: There we go!
PewDiePie: NO NO NO NO! Mark: HAHA, aww
Ken: Like Call of Dut-ay
Ken: Pew pew pew!
Ken: You can't contain yourself!
Mark: I'm on a roll, baby (SCREAMS)
Mark: No! My kill, my kill! Ken: Eh? No, no- eh-eh eh ooo-ooh
Jack: OW OW OW, FELIX WHERE ARE YOU?
Jack: (Squeal) Mark: Yeees! Jack: FUCK IT!
Yeeeaus, yehe- AH
RUN, JUMP, SWING! (Felix: "NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO")
Ken: Jesus, the 360's!
(More screams and a giggling Mark)
Mark: Oh... hehe... God!
Felix: NO NO NO
Jack: Oooh, I'm comin' for ya!
Ken: How do you reload? Oh, R, 'course
Jack: AH! OH, OH Mark: HE WAS OVER THERE, HE WAS HIDING, YES!
Felix: WHY DO YOU SHOOT ME???
Because you were hiding!
Jack: Why did you take my kill, Ken? You fuck!
(Mark giggles)
Ken: I'm out of bullets, Jack (screams)
Felix: I hate all of you guys, you all suck! You're not even good boxes!
Ooooohhh...  Ken: How dare you?
Felix: Yeah, that's right, that's right. Ken: I'm an Apache helicopter(lulz)
Felix: AAAHHHH, YOU PUSHED ME DOWN! Ken: (Laughs) I didn't push you off shit
Come 'ere, come 'ere, come 'ere! I wanna show you somethin'
AWWWWHHHH!
Jack: Did you know that holding the box cutter makes you run faster? Ooohhh
Ooohhh
CS-GO rules
Aahhh... Ken and Felix:  F*c k you! (Laughing)
HEY- woah... Felix: Get sniped, bitch!
Ken: I saw you stop and stare at me like, "no way..."
(Mark and everyone make strange noises)
(Starts panicking) I can't reload fast enough!
Ken: Shit!Box cutter's so dangerous Mark: Eh-hehehe! Ahhh! Jack: (Screams)
CORNERED! CORNERED!
Kenpai:F*ck the guns
Yeah, exactly
(karate sounds)
AAAAAHHHH
Fuckin' Fuck.
(Wheezy laugh)
(Mark laughing)
Felix: You pussy ass pitch-- Bitch. Yeah that's right.
(all giggle)
ow OW KEN NO!
it's your graaave!
ah fu.. god danmit
OOOHH!
YEAH!...
YES!
OH GOD! i want to win!
i want to win
AH! oh god!
*Grunting*
*Screaming for murder*
No (X4) (notice me Senpai Mark ~ grumpycat2528)
The grider is the real one here
Where are you
I swear to god
*Squicky scream*
What you talking about not me
Mills anyone in years but I guess
brother
ah-oh died more though is because I
shown the grinder it's not my fault
stupid game to all right should we do
another game gamer me
yeah yeah alright thank and vs jack are
ya got this course in the last round so
we got hell yea right Diana hey all
right whatever you said can we get this
friendly fire on a no
mashenka locks well okay how about you
direct your anger towards the NICU camp
yeah I want you to your jogging circle
yeah I have to be to be sneaky
I don't know if we can be sneaky this I
hope ya big daddy yeah what the fuck my
god I'm moving as mappers huge defeat
talking about it through over there in
the warehouse
ok zynga can ica get boxes god
rushing you yeah where'd you go
pretty good i don't know try said I'm
going again kempin/getty corner
oh he's cornered that she has a gun cool
yeah he's got a gun violence / found him
to i'm also found him
don't fucking box 100 the fucking box me
brew ok imma get him help from the rear
is apparently really good at this game
is behind the back
oh this is why only my pay my name is
here i am but I'm I'm really for my
laugh
Christ you avenge me
yeah Oh red she okay
yes maybe got him talking spine oh yeah
I'm gonna reach around and wait help I
got him he was high
I got him e 0 and for fuck's sake man
was already dead night fucking get ready
go
I he's hiding he blended and start still
no I'm not having any attack in a bad
mood all the boxes boxes now I don't
have been some minor okay get it
felix is your time to show where I can't
yeah we're still waiting for somebody to
go and be like you have one cool just
point it out because you took my fucking
kill man who decide to be sneaky
ok where are you going to our tactic now
you steal our yeah good plan
oh yeah sweet yeah
editor i c'n dannis apartment it's a lie
Foxtrot Delta Nu diner running away from
me your fucking mom you mean box box
truck box trial today I'll go talk like
you're thinking ever again
alright Jack Jack I might need
assistance tonight
yeah go get hurt he's hurt
don't worry screw your herd so my 360
noscope i'm stuck going oh I would sort
of it I don't get it everywhere
do you realize where my yeah I see them
we're coming up the rear with we're feed
that career I don't think my box has a
butthole so I don't know which is the
rear
yeah that's right on the back you
staring at the whole time oh that's a
wide smile I like it hey I'm oh ok I'm
election will begin block her out she
likes differ press ok I'm trying I'm
trying I'm trying to see what the air
ok text wrapping crew quarters did it
ok you go Tommy okay go get a dude it at
it you do you do lose it
dude I don't see one night and turnin
there being little bitches don't
determine then we're gonna lose your
freedom we got an equaliser yeah no idea
what hey guys today is for joy
I don't think you don't I don't do that
Denton editor didn't ya
wow we have the high ground you can't
win
o.o yea high ground water yes to this
wall fuck's sake in I think it's gonna
run away now he's no confidence in
himself
yeah so pressing for what do ya if I ran
away where you still shooting the boxes
I mean not that I would know that ok
gonna get some sneaky shots on us like
the sweet he is
is that how sweet work they'd always
behind
oh why did you get your dude I didn't I
gotta show you didn't say I hope we're
gonna be chasing him get that fucking
Irish piece of shit
yeah oh yeah okay oh look who's back in
the game
yeah yeah well word corpse that they
seem to be pissing on there that might
help is right around the corner
OIC she can't move that over there over
there can become a fast-acting pincer
movement i told you there were over
there there yes good job Joe Baca the
tail yeah oh yeah oh yeah sure sure the
fuck outta here
oh yeah those be a pic i went for the
high five shot in the face instead berry
I got scared i thought it was there the
same area but this map looks to see
anywhere you don't know can you don't
know anything
oh that's perfect that's pretty good
yeah you look good to stop spinning
ok ok see anyone i don't either but then
again i can only see like two feet in
front of me
you can see the bottom before haha yeah
i can just see your box whole I mean
it's nice and all but I don't want to
see that you're sneaking around
not really no are you guys fighting two
are we both just hiding
oh I see him are you just gonna check
every box can like what do you mean what
the fuck else am I gonna do I see ya
just patience and wait for the right
moment lol me there is a God got my
cells left that I I'm 400 Jack come here
Jack Jack had come here look behind them
how did not look behind that path it is
a trap box
oh yeah
let me shake ya mashaykhina the corner
oh yeah no no you're stuck haha you set
up your stock so epic
I'm violent when I'm cornered yeah he's
like yeah I'm still here
ok we're ever and ever you can't kill
nobody coming to get you buddy
yeah it was he how did you get in there
ah good and there's no prior criminal
record
yeah they were all looking at me in my
sad situation and really like you out of
there to shop but I'm glad I was dead
ok way how's it going
okay uh yeah right i don't know man
likes to kill my dogs
I got this kind of problem but we got it
believe any pic haha yeah we did it yay
how it feels like a hollow victory
change teammate nobody wants to kill
your feelings come on I'll do it
there you go yeah i'm going to reveal
all of the Jackson High strategy
what oh yeah hey hey now what he did was
he was a total douchebag the entire time
and while i was distracting and catching
all the bullets he snuck up from behind
and killed everybody so got a goblin you
distract catch all the bullets really
don't kill it
are you got it this is she supposed to
do it do it
this is a pneumatic I don't recognize
like yeah this looks different em what
happened where'd you go
what you are with me I don't I thought
you all right
was that a battle cry in it that was you
know get in it did it oh jeez did it
that just sounds intimidating did and
just started where you get ya where you
get a dead end we'll just wait here
it'll be a low scoring around every okay
haha oh fuck
uh-huh oh my like and your foot
I'm helping I'm helping my husband yes
ok can you be so sure addict
oh yeah I did it I did it for me that's
yes I read the part of your pocket you
call only the best ever yeah okay I got
here never find never find the finest
before spinning around like a top but I
need this he put you through bad i'll
see this way you see that way
okay i don't know which way is good then
I think you do
ok I I mean I don't even know what makes
the nervous game doesn't help us at all
do your torture always hear that cat
Yeah right there they have no idea how
they are welcome everyone's Lions even
Jack I'm gonna get it i'm going to get a
better be better vantage I get there
did you actually see them know you asked
that weight and you know I see him
oh I love you
yeah good job guess I kind of it all
right here
it's not like this my e oh hello there
girly scream it's too late it's too good
I smell fish those states and it's one
is right in front of each other yeah you
find him
yeah he's right here what happened when
you're quick I'm coming Felix great
coming hey oh shit I'm ready I'm ready
yeah back I'll then do this is the same
place I killed you before you should
have learned I recognize this place
I'm gonna get that advantage . again
maybe I could very soundly know exactly
where we are
Shh no they don't let me go to that same
spot how did the finest who I think it's
your choice
it was a CAD I'm cabin bag
so here it's the same place I killed you
before her chicken with me about your
miles away who I'm ready for anything
wanted me to go dad and Denton he's
healing i know that yes you better go
find him
okay yeah where am i headed and another
net it's the Tramp it's scary out blow
it look
you sneaky fucking hard
Oh behind find this free body sucks dick
going to cut it anymore
it's so annoying about can i really
wanna get your UI jump in your fucking
box nice to have another one another one
I got stuck yeah yeah I got here I gotta
hit up in your grill in the wrong place
but who sits walked into the wrong i'm
literally on fire
this game is stressing me out man yeah
me too alright everyone watching yeah
I'm thank you
I've ngu day man but look at home my god
about corner go boxing man oh man
they're surrounding me jack
what ya you then it gets tips to deal
you're fucking oh there was two of them
that's why it's weird it was 20
no we got three minutes we got a whole
under this this for some reason this
area's the death area yesterday that
there yeah okay okay i don't know what
you're lookin but I'm looking this way
I'm looking around i watch our 6 i'll
watch our right that one
ok I don't like this i'm hiding when I
don't know if you can't find us we win
oh yeah which is why is it good . it's a
good strategy shut up i'm not moving for
shit who I oh I think I think they might
be here come up
yeah I oh god I'm surrounded the Greek
and yet what bargain yeah shit that's my
hair that's about it
he's good start good start yet really
have my ID and tactic
wait when I find all those good high
five shot put him on TV Mackey boat top
of the mortgagee to poopy
oh fuck i avenged you just this so this
is what comes you wish i was doing the
knife fight you pulled out a gun your
stupidity that looks like we're gonna
win and second all anti climatically ya
know ya mean
go get around yeah yeah yeah
that book is the word clear huh yeah
that's right and the room is called join
this Felix and the password is idiot
wrong power
wait what was the password you idiot
yeah fuckin barking like a fucking about
your body
how dare you i'm gonna patch helicopter
yeah I'm an Apache helicopter that baby
does it really is really coming to like
really get popular here lately I don't
know what the bill that is you you have
I think everyone else is ignoring the
objective ken yeah it damn it damn up my
bubble that's it you brought a
box-to-box pay a box to my box and put
her fight ahead max swipe in at the last
minute
haha yeah haha everything without me ask
you haha i was like maybe I should wait
a little bit in case someone walks past
your information of a beach right well
since my son was in here we sit here
dude never burn meet ya don't come up
from behind
ok ok ok i want to i won't do it i want
to dammit max max been a key
no I just realized that's going into a
sense like boxes can we
oh how did that even know one get it now
I get it
the beach yeah well fuck you then I
believe it
yeah what you want to do you have you
have openly don't cut my butt
good night i was the box before your
inborn I got zero . i like it is games
like the commentary all turns into a
bunch of noises just like some sexy
faces on
oh my box is good oh yeah I guess
fuck this stupid feelings here I don't
like a lot of my place I could you say
that to me
Thank You Dale you're playing here
oh I see you but you never know down the
wrong one fucking minute yet
felix is behind you I'm not the FBI haha
not going full circle
it's mine
whoo-hoo yes okay dammit
hello this is hit all the sports car
makes you run faster
oh I said that the first everything on
reloading uh-huh
I can't contain myself coming back who's
here you want fire out of its me bitches
who is what are you doing and was
walking the neighborhood you stop at ya
bro you guys literally oh oh my that can
be arranged it back ok rock out yeah she
did it you did it again to the house
next level
I saw bat in his hands who where are you
yeah yeah fucking piece of movie that's
how we can see here and that's how you
see me shooting that I see him
yeah I be shot from just this is oh my
god is good
happy wait where'd that come can
reassure it here love your laugh haha
haha yeah okay I'm good idea a roofless
you soon so be watching the noise you
make when you box bitch
yeah that's what you deserve ok still
hear ya hear ya
wait what that's like he's been here
waiting to make 2924 you could you guys
suck
there's one more in here under the nice
you don't know that there is no worries
there
damn it i don't know why i didn't
believe you scared me check your kid to
who shoot him
yeah I want you now
Oh dad and he's around the strategy in
the red mow the fucking dogs if it's me
shit dammit we have the same amount of
points Jagger yeah okay what you have
too much health that's all that's not
right . right thanks jack
fuck's sake no no no . read more . . for
Jack
I'm ceasefire it's not here anymore
yeah i got that space
no haha oh no where you are with us here
to help me out damn it i wanna win so
badly
oh yeah I don't wanna win anyways ready
for LA recording everybody we're all
here but everyone's trying to be sneaky
yeah fuck you fuck off
wait you were there the whole topic for
you have to work you can someone is
already here he said the baby's feelings
you've used the same damage can you plug
it at all
ok I got everything I had my knife out
John dip he shit
hey can we gonna make this my Stabbin
stay here feels can't win fuck fuck up
doing anyhow he's in the foot on roids
no don't shoot me . audio and what is
wrong with you
39 ways you died the most to how you got
my god is about Tony turbody always said
it it's a pony